GET STARTED PLEASE. HELLO
EVERYONE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JENNIFER HAVE FILLED I'M AN
OCCUPATIONAL NURSE PRACTITIONER
FOR CAPITAL SERVICES HERE AT
THE CAPITOL AND I AM YOUR
MODERATOR TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US WELCOME TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BRIEFING ON THE
NOVEL CORPS OF CORONAVIRUS COVE
IN NINETEEN YOU ARE ENCOURAGED
TO SHARE THE INFORMATION YOU
WERE HERE TODAY WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES WHO CANNOT ATTEND
THIS MEETING. IT IT AT AND THIS
BRIEFING IS BEING. A LIVE
STREAMED AND WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR VIEWING IN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY TV ARCHIVES. SO IF YOU
HAVE ANYBODY WHO HAD ISN'T HERE
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THIS
IN ABOUT TWENTY FOUR HOURS IT
WILL BE THERE. WE COGNIZANT OF
THE FACT THOUGH THAT THE-
INFORMATION IS OBVIOUSLY
CHANGING DATA BY DAY AND WHAT
INFORMATION RARE TODAY MIGHT
NOT BE RELEVANT TOMORROW BUT-
DEFINITELY WE'RE GONNA GET SOME
GOOD BASIC INFORMATION TODAY.
WE WILL HEAR INTRODUCTIONS FROM
OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE CHAIR
PERSONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
WOOD AND SENATOR. RICHARD PAN
AND THEN WE WILL FOLLOW WITH
OPENING- OPENING REMARKS FROM
THEM AND THEN I PRESENTATION
FROM OUR OUR PANELISTS HERE
TODAY. AFTER THAT WE WERE TAKE
QUESTION FROM OUR- AND WE ALSO
LIVE STREAMING THIS TO OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES WHO CAN
EMAILING QUESTIONS OR UP
ALREADY. EMAIL JUST QUESTIONS
HELLO AT WILL ANSWER THOSE
AFTER THE PANEL HAS SPOKEN WITH
US TODAY IS DOCTOR SONYA ANGEL
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. DR
JAMES WHAT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND ACTING STATE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. DOCTOR KERRY
BYINGTON EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF YOU SEE. A DOCTOR
PETER BILL INCIDENT DIRECTOR OF
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICE.
SERVICES THANK YOU PANEL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE KNOW YOU
HAVE A VERY BUSY SCHEDULE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR- OUR MEMBERS-
DO A BRIEF OPENING AND THEY
WERE GONNA HAVE DOCTOR BILL
IT'S AND SPEAK. RIGHT AWAY
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS. AND HE'S
GONNA HAVE TO NEED THE EARLY SO
WITH THAT I'LL LIKE TO
INTRODUCE. CENTER RICHARD PAN.
GREAT THANK YOU SO VERY I'M NOT
RICHARD PAN ON THE OF THE SENT
HEALTH COMMITTEE ALSO PHYSICIAN
WITH BACK PUBLIC HOW. AND I
JUST WANT FOR OF ALL. WOKE
EVERYONE HERE WE ARE THE MIDST.
A AND- OF A OF CORONA. IS STAFF
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF YOUR
MEMBERS- YOU NEED TO MODEL WHAT
WE WANT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
TO DO SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S SO IMPORTANT
ABOUT YOU BEING HERE AND
LEARNING ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
THE CORONA VIRUS- WE NEED TO
SEND A MESSAGE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO NOT PANIC THERE
ARE THINGS WE GO AND ASK PEOPLE
TO DO- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES MAY NEED TO ASK
PEOPLE TO DO THAT MAY BE
SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT AT TIMES.
AND PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE FAITH
AND TRUST IN OUR LEADERSHIP AND
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERSHIP TO
CARRY THOSE THINGS OUT AND HOW
WIRE TO GOING TO FAITH
ENTRUSTED BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
TURNED PEOPLE LIKE YOURSELVES
YOU WHO REPRESENTS. THE PEOPLE
THEY- AND THAT WHEN YOU EXPRESS
THAT CONFIDENCE THEN PEOPLE
WILL FEEL THAT CONFIDENCE AND
IF YOU DON'T PANIC THEY WILL
NOT PANIC SO I KNOW YOU'RE HERE
NOT BECAUSE YOU WANT TO PANIC
BUT YOU HAVE QUESTIONS WILL BE
SURE YOU HAVE THOSE ANSWERS SO
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT KNOWING THIS. REALLY
CHANGING AND FLEW TO A YOU
ACTUALLY UP HERE NOT ONLY PETER
IS A OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND P.
WHO I'LL TELL YOU AS IF ALSO
HOW VERY HIGH REPEAT AROUND A
CO AS A IN THE FIELD SO THIS I
IN ADDITION TO JUST AND VISION
TO BEING LEADERS HE AND TELL.
THERE WELL RESPECTED OUT FEEL
YOU CAN GET SOME GOOD GOOD
ANSWER SOME MAYBE I'M NOT SURE.
OKAY BECAUSE WE'RE STILL STUFF
OUT BUT WE WANT YOUR QUESTIONS
THE OTHER THING I'LL JUST ONE
NOTE THIS IS WE HAVE PUBLIC
HEALTH ACT UP HERE SOME OF YOU
MAY HAVE TO REGARDING THINGS
ARE HR THINGS THOSE TO ASK
HUMAN RESOURCES WE'RE NOT
CERTAIN QUESTIONS CERTAINLY AT
THE VERY RULES. WE WILL ANSWER
YOUR HEALTH QUESTIONS BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT FOR YOUR YOUR FOR.
THE MORE PER FOR THE CA. THAT
YOU WORKING FOR SO WITH THAT
AGAIN I WANT YOU OFFER BEING
HERE A- ALL THE PEOPLE UP HERE
IN THE PANEL. AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK HARD TO BE
SURE WE COMMUNICATE ACTOR
INFORMATION TO YOU AND
REMEMBER. OUR GOING BE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND OKAY WITH US
ON. WOULD OKAY. AS SO REMEMBER
HEALTH. HEALTH CAN. CHAIR PER.
A MEMBER JIM WHAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I JUST
OBVIOUSLY. IS CAN. ALLOW OF OUR
TEN THE- WANTS ANSWERS NEEDS
ANSWERS WE ALL WANT ANSWERS- I
JUST WANNA A- COMMAND THE
LEADERSHIP OF DR ANTHONY FAUCI
AND AS- NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
ALLERGY. AND INFECTIOUS
DISEASE- DOCTOR GALLEY OUR OWN.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY. DOCTOR
SONYA ANGEL- PUBLIC HEALTH.
DEPARTMENT THEIR LEADERSHIP HAS
BEEN IMPRESSIVE- AND- THE MORE
IMPORTANTLY IMPORTANTLY AND
THAT IS THE DELIVERING. OF
SCIENTIFIC- ACCURATE.
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION AND-
THAT HELPS US TO RIDE HOME
WITHIN THE EXISTING STORM- I
WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK GOD THE
OUR ENTIRE HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY. FOR TIRELESSLY
TREATING PATIENTS AND HELPING
THE- UNDER. THE TRUE RISK- IT
IS A IT IS A CHALLENGE IT IS AN
EVER. EVOLVING TO WAIT IN AND-
WITH. I'M CONFIDENT THEY WE
HAVE. THE LEVEL. OPPRESSIVE
LEADERSHIP TO. US THROUGH THIS
THROUGH THE STORM SO. BUT
HEARING FROM OUR- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY.
OKAY NECK WE WILL GET A PRISON.
FROM OUR PANEL. AND WE WILL
START DOWN THE LINE IF DOCTOR
JAMES WHAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
FIRST NO EXCUSE ME I WOULD LIKE
PETER FILL IN SADDAM PEELING.
IT'S AN YOU'RE GOING TO SPEAK
FOR LIKE. PARDON ME. ABOUT
FIFTY YEARS AGO MY DAD SAID
THIS EXACT CHAIR AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE STATE SENATE COMMITTEE. ON
HEALTH AND SO IT'S VERY GREAT
PLEASURE TO SIT HERE AS WELL SO
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
COME FROM BALTIMORE AS WELL.
AND IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE'VE
GONE FROM WAS CALLED THE
CONTAINMENT STRATEGY WHICH IS.
SORT OF A BLUNT OBJECT OF
DOING- CONTACT TRACING AND
QUARANTINING OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME TO HAVE CONTACT WITH
PATIENTS. TO A MITIGATION
STRATEGY WHICH IS MITIGATING OR
LESSENING THE REST TO THOSE WHO
ARE MOST SIGNIFICANT RISK FROM
THIS ILLNESS. AND WE HAVE NOW-
EYES SO NOBLE DOCTOR ANGEL WILL
TALK MUCH ABOUT THIS BUT WE
HAVE NOW AT LEAST THREE MONTHS
WORTH OF EVIDENCE ABOUT- AND
THE FINANCES OVERWHELMING AT
THE FOLLOWING IS TRUE- A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF CASES
ARE EITHER MILD OR A
SYMPTOMATIC. KIDS AT LEAST AS
OF THE DATE APPEAR TO BE MORE
BENIGNLY AFFECTED OTHERS
PERCENT. TAX PROBABLY LESS OF
THAN BY THE FLU. AND THAT
SENIORS UNDENIABLY ARE THE ONES
ARE MOST AT RISK AND THOSE WITH
CHRONIC UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
AND THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE MITIGATION STRATEGY. TO
DECREASE EXPOSURE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE SICK TO SENIORS AND TO
DECREASE EXPOSURE OF SENIORS TO
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE SET. AND
GATHERING AREAS IT CETERA. SO
WHAT ARE WE RECOMMENDING- IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THIS IS
ALSO RAPIDLY CHANGING AS I YOU
GUYS PROBABLY SAW AS YOU'RE
WALKING IN THE CDC JUST
IMPLEMENTED NEW GUIDELINES- TEN
PAGES WORTH OF GUIDELINES. FOR
THE MITIGATION STRATEGY. BUT IN
MITIGATION STRATEGY WE ARE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK
TO STAY HOME. THESE ARE NON THE
NON- HIGH RISK PEOPLE PEOPLE
ARE SICK TO STAY HOME. PEOPLE
WHO ARE SICK AND HAVE SYMPTOMS
THAT ARE SOMEWHAT SIGNIFICANT
TO CALL THEIR DOCTOR BEFORE
THEY GO INTO THE URGENT CARE
CENTER OR TO THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT. THEY
CAN'T TREAT THE CASE FROM HOME.
PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO HAVE
SERIOUS- COMPS SYMPTOMS. OR
LIFE THREATENING SYMPTOMS
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD GO TO THE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOM AND
PART OF THE REASON FOR
MEDICATION STRATEGIES TO
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
COMING INTO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND HOSPITALS TO MAINTAIN. OUR
SIR PASSAGE IF YOU IF YOU WELL
BY LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THAT COME IN
THERE WITH THE INTERNET IS VERY
COME. FOR THIS. ON THE SIDE. WE
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT DAY AVOID
AND THIS IS ALSO IN THE CDC
GUIDELINES. THAT THEY AVOID-
MASS GATHERINGS- AND INCLUDING
PLACES WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE-
ACCUMULATE LIKE MALLS. GROCERY
STORES IF YOU IF YOU DON'T HAVE
KIDS WHO CAN GO TO YOUR GROCERY
STORE FOR YOU AT LEAST GO ON
OFF HOURS AND GET TWO OR THREE
WEEKS AT A TIME. MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE. THE MEDICATIONS ON HAND
THAT CAN BE MAILED TO YOU
VENTURA PET- POTENTIALLY. AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS AND
AVOIDING HE EVENTS. WHERE YOU
DON'T NEED TO GO TO. SO THAT'S
THE MITIGATION STRATEGIES THAT
THE FOLLOWING IN THE COUNTY.
AND IT'S BEEN A BIT OF A CHANGE
OF THE PEOPLES THAT WE GAVE. UP
ON CONTAINMENT BUT EXACTLY. AT
COLLEGE. THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
DAY. QUE NOW. AND IT MAKES TO
AND DECREASE THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE FURTHER I'M
PARTICULARLY TO THOSE WHO ARE
AT SIGNIFICAN NO SIGNIFICANT
RISK OF KIND OF HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
BILLINGTON THINK OF THE DID YOU
WANT IT HAS DO YOU CAN AT CAN
INTO IF YOU WERE WANTED UP OUR
FELLOWS TIME BUT IF YOU HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR SACRAMENTO
SPECIFIC THINGS. OR NOT. I
THINK YOU WERE VERY SPECIFIC
AND CLEAR ABOUT THAT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
HERE APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY SO
NEXT SO WE'LL JUST GO DOWN THE
LINE OR WOULD YOU LIKE DR SONI
ANGEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT WOULD THAT
BE GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO ALSO DOCTOR FOR THAT THAT
ENTERED BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT IT IS VERY LOCAL IN OUR
EXPERIENCE OF IT RIGHT SO
COMMUNITIES ARE HAVING
DIFFERENT RATES OF THEIR FIRST
TRAVEL RELATED CASE OR THEIR
FIRST CASE OF COMMITTEE
TRANSMISSION AND AS SUCH ARE
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN REACTING
AND RESPONDING BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS MADE UP OF MANY
CAL COMMUNITIES AND SO HAVING
THIS PICTURE OF ONE AND A VERY
DEAR LOCAL ONE AND ALSO WHEN IT
IS IT IS EXPERIENCING A FAIR
BURDEN. OF DISEASE AT THE TIME
AT THIS TIME I THINK IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT WAY TO OPEN IT
UP TO REALLY GET A SENSE OF
WHERE IN FACT PERHAPS OF MOST
IF NOT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
OF MAY GET TO- COULD VERY WELL
GET TO- BUT THE WHOLE REASON
THAT WE ARE REACTING AND
RESPONDING IN THE WAY THAT WE
ARE IS THA WE ARE WORKING VERY
HARD TO EITHER DELAY OR PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING- IN ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES LET ME JUST
TAKE A QUICK STEP BACK. IN A
AND I AT FIRST THE KNOWLEDGE
AND- THIS OP. BECAUSE ONE OF
THE- MùT. IN ALLEN OF A NEW
VIRUS THAT COMES INTO THE
COMMUNITY IS. PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
RIGHT THAT'S THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S NEW. AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID. AND WHEN IS
COMPLEMENTED BY A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION WHICH THERE IS
WHEN ANYTHING'S NEW PEOPLE CAN
MAKE UP STUFF THERE ISN'T AS
MUCH SCIENCE TO SAY THAT'S NOT
TRUE THAT'S NOT TRUE. IT STARTS
TO FEED THAT THE F. FUEL THE
FIRE AND- AND SO I THINK AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
HAVE HERE ALL OF THE- IS TO
SHARE THE FACTS. THAT YOU CAN
ALSO SHARE THEM IN YOUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THAT IS THE
ONE THING. WILL HELP US ADDRESS
TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY IS WHEN
WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
LIMIT FEAR. AND REALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT UNCERTAINTY.
UNCERTAINTY IS TO BE EXPECTED.
AND MY TELEPHONE RINGING IS NOT
TO BE EXPECTED I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. BUT THEY'RE VERY CLEAR
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO
PROTECT OURSELVES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SO THIS IS A VIRUS
APPEARED IN- IN AT THE END OF.
THIS VERY LAST YEAR AND- ALMOST
A MONTH LATER WE HAD OUR VERY
FIRST CASE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEN JUST AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS MONTH WE HAD OUR FIRST-
ARE FOR STAFF SADLY IN OUR
STATE. THIS IS A THIS VIRUS AND
AT AS DR- BILLIONS IN WAS IT
MENTIONED HAS ALSO BROUGHT US
ON A PATH WHICH FIRST STARTED
IN TERMS OF INTERVENTIONS WITH
A VERY STRONG FOCUS ON
CONTAINMENT SO YOU RECALL THAT
WE- WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
FOCUSING ON PEOPLE. ENTERING
THE COUNTRY FROM ABROAD PEOPLE
ENTERING SPECIFICALLY TO BEGIN
WITH FROM CHINA ALL KINDS OF
THE MONITORING THAT WOULD OCCUR
IF THEY LET CAME FROM CHINA
OVERALL AND IN FACT QUARANTINE
IF THEY CAME FROM THE EPICENTER
OF WHERE THE- INFECTION FIRST
WAS DETECTED. THAT IS A
STRATEGY THAT VERY EARLY ON IS
OFTEN IMPLEMENTED BUT AT SOME
POINT IN PARTICULAR WHEN WE GET
TO THE POINT OF COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION. THAT CONTAINMENT
FOCUS THAT FOCUS ON INDIVIDUALS
REALLY TRYING TO GET AROUND
THEM INTO ALL CONTACT TRACING
TO PREVENT. ANYBODY ELSE FROM
GETTING IT. BECOMES LESS
EFFECTIVE. AND WE START TO MOVE
TOWARDS IS PERIOD OF
MITIGATION. AND IN MITIGATION I
THINK IT'S EASIEST TO DESCRIBE
IT AS FROM GOING TO FOCUSING ON
INDIVIDUALS. TO GOING TO
FOCUSING ON COMMUNITIES AND WE
ARE MAKING THAT TRANSMITS
TRANSITION NOW AND I USE THAT
LANGUAGE BECAUSE YOU HEAR THAT
A LOT IN THE MEDIA RIGHT NOW.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S NOT SO CLEAR
WHAT IT MEANS TO GO FROM. A
CONTAINMENT TO MITIGATION BUT
IN ESSENCE WHERE WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING A LOT OF OUR TIME AND
RESOURCES NOW IS MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE POPULATION WHO ARE.
MOST VULNERABLE THE ONES WHO
ARE MOST LIKELY TO GET INTO.
SERIOUS TROUBLE IF THEY ARE IN
FACT INFECTED ARE PREVENTED
FROM BEING EXPOSED THAT'S OUR
FOCUS AT THIS TIME AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE ALL MOVING
TOGETHER. SO AS WE MAKE THIS
TRANSITION. FROM INDIVIDUAL
CASES TO COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION
AT APPROPRIATELY OUR APPROACH
IS ARE ALSO CHANGING AND THAT'S
WHY YOU'RE HEARING DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES GOING ON ACROSS
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. AT
DIFFERENT RATES. SO IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NOW REACHED
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVEN CASES A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE OF THOSE. ARE NOT REALLY
RELATED TO THE REPATRIATION
FLIGHT SO THERE IS A SMALL
NUMBER. THAT HAS NOT CHANGED
ITS AT TWENTY FOUR THAT WAS DUE
TO THE REPATRIATION FLIGHTS
THAT CAME INTO THE- THE STATE
WHERE WE'RE SEEING THE GROWTH
NOW. IS IN TRAVEL RELATED AND
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION LARGELY
HERE IN THE STATE I WANNA SAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR RESPONSE
TODAY BECAUSE WHILE MANY PEOPLE
MAY HAVE THINK OF OUR RESPONSE
HAVING STARTED. YOU KNOW WHEN
WE FIRST HEARD ABOUT IT IN FACT
OUR RESPONSE HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR OVER A DECADE. WE STARTED
PLANNING FOR A PANDEMIC LONG
AGO AND THOSE PLANS HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE UPDATED AND
REVISED OVER TIME FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH THE BALL OUT
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE OF H. ONE
AND ONE AND THE SECOND THAT WE
HEARD ABOUT THIS AGAIN WE-
DUSTED OFF AGAIN DUSTING OFF
ISN'T PERHAPS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BECAUSE IT SITS. IN A
COMPUTER BUT WE PULLED IT OUT
AND STARTED GOING THROUGH IN
THINKING VERY QUICKLY AND EVER
SINCE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS AS
WE GOT NEW INFORMATION
UNDERSTANDING THE MODE OF
TRANSMISSION THE INCUBATION
PERIOD THE DURATION OF
INFECTIVITY. UNDERSTANDING
WHERE IT'S MOVING AROUND THE
WORLD AT WHAT RATE AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY WE'VE CONTINUED TO
REVISE OUR APPROACH AND WE'VE
CONTINUE TO INTRODUCE CHANGING
INTERVENTIONS THAT RELATE TO
THAT. ACROSS THIS ENTIRE TIME
COURSE WE'VE BEEN VERY
AGGRESSIVE AT RELEASING
GUIDANCE GUIDANCE THAT APPLIES
TO SPECIFIC POPULATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS.
UGH GUIDE OUR COMMUNITY
MEASURES A GUIDANCE FOR WORK
PLACES ALL OF THOSE AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY IN EVIDENCE TRANSLATES
INTO WAY WE ALL OF US BEHAVE
EVERY DAY AND COMMUNITIES AND
HOME WILL PLAY. IN THE PLACE
WHERE WE WORSHIP AND WE PLAY WE
ALSO IN. TING PHONE CALLS AND
OTHER CA. AND OR ARE COME COME.
WITH OUR LOCAL HEALTH AUTHORITY
ACROSS STATE WITH ARE CARED.
PLANNED FOR. AND LEADERS.
BECAUSE IN THE END THE THINGS
THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. ON THE
FRONTLINE OF ISMAKING SURE
THAT INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
UNDERSTAND WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND CAN USE
THEM IN A WAY THAT IS GUIDED BY
THE EVIDENCE. AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN PARTICULAR HAS THE RESOURCES
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND EFFECTIVELY. THOSE ARE
THE TWO AREAS WHERE WE SPENT
MOST OF OUR TIME FOCUSING ON.
CONCURRENTLY WITH THAT WE'VE
ALSO BEEN GATHERING AT THE
STATE LEVEL SO WE ARE ACTIVATED
AT LEVEL ONE RESPONSE RIGHT NOW
THAT'S THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
RESPONSE THAT CAN EXISTED BUT
IN IN RISK. IN RESPONSE TO AN
EMERGENCY- WE HAVE DONE A TABLE
TOP THAT IS INCLUDED ALL OF OUR
SENIOR GOVERNMENT LEADERSHIP.
ACROSS EVERY AGENCY THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS TO THINK VERY
CAREFULLY NOT ONLY ABOUT HOW IT
AFFECTS GOVERNMENT BUT HOW ALL
OF OUR RESOURCES IN GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD AND CAN BE MOBILIZED TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
AS WE UNDERSTAND. THE WAY THE
DISEASE'S MOVING WE'VE INVESTED
IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
TESTING IN THE STATE. I IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS AND I'M
DOCTOR WHAT WE'LL TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT AS WELL. MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE A WHEN THE STING IN
VAIL TO GET AVAIL THE IN
PARTICULAR IN THOSE CASES. THAT
IT CAN AND IS IN CRITICAL TO
DIVIDE TO. GUIDE TREATMENT AND
MANAGEMENT OF PATIENTS IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. I WANTED AS
THOUGH THAT OF THE THINGS THAT
NO MATTER WHERE YOU SIT IN WHAT
SYSTEM YOU ARE THE WITH THE IF.
A CRITICAL THING IS THAT WE
BOTH STAY INFORMED AND SO THE
CDC. OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
LOCAL AND COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
ALL HAVE WEBSITES WHERE WE PUSH
OUT THE MOST RECENT FACTS AND
ALSO THE MOST RECENT GUIDANCE
AND SO AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
YOUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
INDIVIDUAL. TO GOT TO RECEIVE
GUIDANCE FROM- AND YOU'RE AT AS
AGREED TO BY YOUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO GET GUIDANCE
FROM ON HOW TO ACT THAT'S MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR UNDERSTANDING
OF KOBE NINETEEN IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. IN ADDITION TO BEING
HAVING THAT INFORMATION AND
USING THE FACTS TO GUIDE- THE
TO SHARE AND TO GUIDE AND
UNDERSTANDING AND TO MANAGE-
THE FACTOR OF FEAR THAT
CERTAINLY CAN ARISE IN THE
SITUATION. THE OTHER THING THAT
ALL OF US NEED TO DO IS JUST
THE TYPICAL THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY DURING
FLU SEASON TO PREVENT- THE
MOVEMENT OF VIRUSES WHICH
INCLUDES COVERING OUR VOWS OF
WHEN WE COUGH OR SNEEZE.
WASHING OUR HANDS FREQUENTLY
AND IMPORTANTLY STAYING HOME IF
YOU'RE NOT WELL ALL OF US NO
MATTER WHAT. THAT'S ONE OF THE
KEY THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO
AT THIS TIME BECAUSE EVEN IF
IT'S NOT COVERT NINETEEN. IF
WE'RE ALL SPREADING ACTIONS
THAT WE HAVE WITH PARTICULAR
THE RESPIRATORY WE'RE ALSO
ADDING TO FEAR IN OUR COMMUNITY
SO THAT'S WHY THINGS LIKE
GETTING YOUR FLU SHOT ALSO IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ACTION
WE STRONGLY STRONGLY RECOMMEND-
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO- GO AHEAD
AND PASS IT OVER BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE ARE OTHER ANSWERS TO THIS
PUZZLE- THAT WILL COME FROM
OTHER. EXPERTS ON THE ON THE
PANEL. THANK YOU DOCTOR HOPE
HILL DR WHAT PLEASE. SURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M I JUST LIKE
TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON CORONAVIRUS
DISEASE SO I'M GONNA BE TALKING
A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM A
MEDICAL PERSPECTIVE. AND LET ME
START BY SAYING THAT WE ARE
LEARNING A LOT ABOUT THIS
DISEASE I'M THIS IS A NEW
DISEASE AND SO REALLY WITH EACH
PASSING DAY THERE'S NEW
INFORMATION COMING OUT AND WE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING HARD TO
STAY UP ON THIS SO THAT WE CAN
INFORM. OTHER KINDS OF RESPONSE
EFFORTS THE DOCTOR ANGEL WAS
TALKING ABOUT. I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS CHANGED ABOUT
THIS DISEASE IS JUST THE NAME
AND YOU PROBABLY HAVE SEEN LOTS
OF DIFFERENT. TERMS USED IN THE
NEWSPAPER LET ME LET ME JUST
CLARIFY THAT A LITTLE BIT. SO
THE DISEASE IS NOW CALLED
CORONAVIRUS DISEASE TWENTY
NINETEEN. OR CODED NINETEEN
THAT'S HOW IT'S ABBREVIATED.
AND THE VIRUS THAT CAUSES IT
HAS NOW BEEN NAMED. SARS
CORONAVIRUS TO. OR SARS KOBE
TO- AND THIS NAME WAS ASSIGNED
BY AN INTERNATIONAL CAN. IT HAS
THE- GIVEN NAMES. AND THEY
STILL DID ON THIS NAME BECAUSE
THE- GEN. RELAY OF NEW. TO
OTHER VIRUSES IS CLOSEST TO THE
SARS CORONAVIRUS SO I GUESS
THEY DECIDED WILL CALL IT SARS
CORONAVIRUS TO. I'M THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING THOUGH
BECAUSE THIS VIRUS DOES NOT
COST SARS IT CAUSES CORONA
VIRUS DISEASE TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THAT DISEASES DIFFERENT
THAN SARS THEY'RE BOTH
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES. BUT
THEIR DIFFERENCE LET ME TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT CORONA VIRUS
DISEASE AND WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
IT. IT'S PRIMARILY A
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS THE MOST
COMMON SYMPTOMS ARE FEVER COUGH
AND FATIGUE SO IN OTHER WORDS
CORONAVIRUS DISEASE TWENTY
NINETEEN LOOKS AND FEELS A LOT
LIKE THE FLOW. AND MORE ALSO I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE INFECTION WITH
SARS CORONAVIRUS TO HAVE NO
SYMPTOMS AT ALL AND THOSE WHO
DO DEVELOP SYMPTOMS HAVE MILD
ILLNESS AND MOST OF THEM CAN BE
MANAGED AT HOME DOING THE
NORMAL THINGS THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND FOR PEOPLE WITH THE
FLU. IN SOME LARGE STUDIES FROM
CHINA ABOUT 80% OF RECOGNIZED
CASES HAVE EITHER NO SYMPTOMS
AT ALL OR MILD SYMPTOMS. NOW
ABOUT 20% OF THE RECOGNIZED
ILLNESSES- HAVE REQUIRED
HOSPITALIZATION IN CHINA WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE WHETHER THERE'LL BE
SOME DIFFERENCES HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES WERE WATCHING
THAT CLOSELY. THIS MAY ACTUALLY
BE- AN OVER ESTIMATE BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S GOOD EVIDENCE
THAT SOME OF THE LESS SERIOUS
INFECTIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
RECOGNIZED SO FAR. BUT FROM
CHINA ABOUT 20% OF THE- CASES
HAVE REQUIRED HOSPITALIZATION
MOST OF THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN
IN THE HOSPITAL HAVE RECOVERED
AND DONE WELL. ANOTHER REASON
SOMEONE WITH COVERT NINETEEN
MIGHT NEED TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL IS THEY MIGHT HAVE
PNEUMONIA OR SOME DIFFICULTY
BREATHING AND NEED SOME MEDICAL
SUPPORT ARE ALSO SUPPORT FOR
THEIR UNDERLYING CONDITIONS. SO
SOMEONE WHO HAS DIABETES FOR
EXAMPLE WHO GETS INFECTED WITH
COVERT NINETEEN MIGHT NEED
EXTRA HELP IN MANAGING THEIR
DIABETES. ABOUT 5% OF
RECOGNIZED CASES IN CHINA HAVE
REQUIRED ADMISSION TO AN
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT. IN ABOUT
2% HAVE DIED. NOW I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THESE DATA COME
FROM CHINA AND MOST OF THE
CHINESE DATA ARE COMING FROM
THE EPICENTER OF WHERE THIS
VIRUS EMERGED IN WHO BAY
PROVINCE. OUTSIDE OF THAT
PROVINCE. IN CHINA THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD A CASE OF THIS DISEASE AND-
HAVE GONE ON TO DIE IS MUCH
LOWER ABOUT HALF OF A PERCENT.
SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES PARTICULARLY
AS WE LEARN ABOUT TREATING
COVERT NINETEEN. THE DEATH RATE
MAY EVEN BE LOWER. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE RISK OF SEVERE DISEASE
AND DEATH IS DIFFERENT FOR
DIFFERENT GROUPS. SO AS DR
BEYONCE AND POINTED OUT THIS
DISEASE- HIS NAME. IS MUCH
TENDS TO BE MUCH MILDER IN
CHILDREN AND THE RISK OF SEVERE
DISEASE DOES INCREASE WITH AGE
AND IT ALSO INCREASES FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS. AND SOME OF
THE REPORTS FROM CHINA HAVE
INDICATED THAT THE RISK OF
SEVERE DISEASE. GOES UP AS
PEOPLE GET INTO THEIR SIXTIES
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES AND
INCREASES AS PEOPLE GET OLDER.
SO AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THAT. PICTURE OF THIS IS
GOING TO BE PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREA OF THE PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SEVERE DISEASE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES- AS
DOCTOR ANGEL POINTED OUT-
PROTECTION OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
OLDER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
HAS BEEN A PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR
RESPONSE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE. AS WE MOVE INTO THIS
MITIGATION FACE. LET ME SAY A
FEW WORDS ABOUT TREATMENT TO
RIGHT NOW TREATMENT IS
PRIMARILY SUPPORTIVE THAT MEANS
MANAGEMENT OF SYMPTOMS AND
SUPPORTING GENERAL HEALTH.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO SPECIFIC
TREATMENTS FOR- COVERT NINETEEN
BUT LET ME SAY MORE ALSO MORE
ABOUT THAT IN A MINUTE. PEOPLE
WITH MILD ILLNESS CAN STAY HOME
AND FOLLOW THE USUAL ADVICE FOR
THE FLU. REST GET PLENTY OF
FLUIDS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
STAYING AWAY FROM OTHERS WHILE
THEY'RE SEC. IF SOMEONE DOES
NEED TO BE HOSPITALIZED THEY
MAY BE TREATED WITH XYGEN AND
FLUIDS AND GIVING CARE FOR
THEIR UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS IF THEY HAVE ANY. IN
AN INTENSIVE CARE UNIT. MORE
INTENSIVE BREEDING SUPPORT CAN
BE PROVIDED. NOW BACK TO
MEDICATIONS THERE ARE SOME
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING TESTED TO SEE IF THEY ARE
EFFECTIVE AGAINST COVERT
NINETEEN THESE MEDICATIONS ARE
AVAILABLE NOW AND ARE BEING
USED FOR SEVERELY ILL PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND AS MORE
PEOPLE GET TREATED WE WILL
LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE
THESE MEDICATIONS ARE. AND IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT WITHIN THE NEXT
MONTH OR TWO WE MAY HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
THAT WOULD BE PARTICULARLY
VALUABLE FOR PEOPLE WITH MORE
SEVERE DISEASE. IN CLOSING I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON
VACCINES BECAUSE THAT'S A
COMMON QUESTION WORK HAS
STARTED ON A COVERT NINETEEN
VACCINE. BUT VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT AND TESTING IS MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT THAN TESTING
MEDICATION SO THIS IS NOT A
MATTER OF MONTHS AS I INDICATED
IT WOULD BE FOR MEDICATIONS.
USUALLY VACCINE DEVELOPMENT AND
TESTING TAKES YEARS WITH THE
INTENSE EFFORT THAT'S BEING
FOCUSED ON COVERT NINETEEN
INCLUDING VACCINE DEVELOPMENT.
THE TIMELINE MIGHT BE SHORTENED
BUT IT'S LIKELY THAT IT WILL BE
AT LEAST A YEAR OR TWO BEFORE
WE SEE A FULLY READY TO GO-
VACCINE FOR THIS CONDITION. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHAT AND NOW WILL HAVE CARE A
DOCTOR BUT BYINGTON SPEAK BUT
WE LOST YOUR- A LITTLE. SHE IS
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF YOU
SEE HEALTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
FOR OF HAVING THIS SESSION AND
THANK YOU TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES. I AGREE WITH EVERY
STATEMENT THAT'S BEEN MADE- SO
FAR- TODAY. AND AS EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR. YOU SEE
HEALTH. OF I WANTED TO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WANTED TO TELL YOU JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND.
MY TITLE MAY NOT NECESSARILY
CONVEY AN AREA OF EXPERTISE. I%
AM A PEDIATRIC INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PHYSICIAN TRAINED AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO. MY PARTICULAR
AREA OF RESEARCH HAS BEEN
RESPIRATORY VIRAL INFECTIONS IN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN I PRACTICE
MY ENTIRE CAREER IN A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. AND I HAVE
WORKED ON OF EMERGING PATHOGENS
AND OTHER INFECTIONS THAT LEAD
TO PANDEMICS. I HAVE WORKED
WITH THE H. ONE N. ONE
INFLUENZA PANDEMIC WITH EBOLA
AND DURING THE SEEK OUT BREAK I
WAS THE LEAD POSITION FOR THE
US OLYMPIC COMMITTEE- IN CHARGE
OF. OF THE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
OLYMPIANS AND PARALYMPIANS
RELATED TO SEEK OUT. AND I'M
GLAD TO SAY THAT NOT ONE OF
OUR- U. S. CONTINGENT A
CONTRACTED SECA DURING OUR TIME
IN BRAZIL. SO I'M VERY PROUD
AND PRIVILEGED TO LEAD THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SYSTEM AT THIS TIME AND FEEL
THAT MY- PAST HISTORY CAN BRING
US SOME EXPERTISE TO THE
SITUATION IN WHICH WE FIND
OURSELVES. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. IS IN REMARKABLE
HEALTH SYSTEM RENOWNED
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
WITH FIVE FLAGSHIP MEDICAL
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR HOSPITALS ARE
MONTHS THE HIGHEST RATED IN THE
UNITED STATES ND IN THE WORLD.
OUR PHYSICIANS AND OUR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AND SCIENTISTS
ARE PREPARED TO ADDRESS THE
THREAT OF COVERT NINETEEN AND
THE PANDEMIC JUST AS DOCTOR
ANGEL SAID WE DID NOT START TO
PREPARE FOR THIS IN DECEMBER WE
BEEN PREPARING FOR THIS FOR
OVER A DECADE. SO ALTHOUGH I'VE
RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA
RELATIVELY RECENTLY IN OCTOBER
LIKE DOCTOR ANGEL UP I HAVE
BEEN SO PLEASED TO SEE THE
COLLABORATIONS THAT EXIST AT UC
HEALTH WITH OUR LOCAL AND STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND WE ARE
WORKING VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH
THESE RESOURCES AM WITH THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL TO
ADDRESS THE THREAT OF COKE
NINETEEN. BECAUSE I'M COMING
FROM THE UC HEALTH SYSTEM I'D
LIKE TO GIVE YOU JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION OF WHAT YOU
SEE HEALTH IS DOING TO ADDRESS.
COVERT NINETEEN AND IT'S REALLY
IN THREE AREAS FIRST THE
DELIVERY OF PATIENT CARE.
SECOND PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THIRD
CONTRIBUTING TO RESEARCH THESE
ARE VERY SPECIFIC AREAS WHERE
AN ACADEMIC HEALTH SYSTEM CAN
BE A OF GREAT SUPPORT. SO FIRST
IN PATIENT CARE. AS EVERYONE
HAS SAID THIS IS CHANGING EACH
DAY AND REALLY HOUR BY HOUR.
YOU SEE HEALTH ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM HAS NOW TAKING CARE OF
ELEVEN PATIENTS WITH COVERT
NINETEEN DISEASE. AN ABOUT
EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR COVERT
NINETEEN DISEASE. ALL OF OUR
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THESE- EVALUATIONS
AND PROVIDING CARE. THESE WERE
THE FIRST PATIENTS CARED FOR IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
REPRESENTED DOES THAT I HAD
TRAVEL ASSOCIATED COVERED
NINETEEN AND THOSE THAT HAD
COMMUNITY ACQUIRED COATED
NINETEEN. AND WITH EACH PATIENT
WE HAVE HAD CLOSE CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE LOCAL
PATIENT LIFT WITH THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE WITH THE STATE AND
WITH THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE DONE HAS INFORMED
THE GUIDANCE AT BOTH THE STATE
AND THE NATIONAL LEVEL FOR THE
CARE OF THESE PATIENTS. SECOND
IS PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU SEE IS A LARGE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AT A AND WE'VE ACROSS THE STATE
AND WE FEEL THAT YOU SEE HEALTH
A SPECIAL ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS WHICH NUMBER ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
TO PROTECT OUR EMPLOYEES WHICH
NUMBERS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. AND SO WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS YOU SO USE
THE HEALTH TO INTERPRET THE
GUIDANCE THAT'S COMING FROM OUR
LOCAL. AND STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THE CDC AND TO
ADAPT THAT GUIDANCE TO MAKE OUR
WORK ENVIRONMENTS AND OUR
EDUCATION ENVIRONMENT AS AS
POSSIBLE. THE OTHER PLACE WHERE
WE REALLY WORKING PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY IS WITH DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING. ALL OF YOU WHO READ
THE NEWSPAPERS AND LISTEN TO
THE NEWS REPORTS NO THAT
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE. OUR MEDICAL CENTER
LABORATORIES ARE ALL WORKING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO INCREASING TEST
AVAILABILITY ALL FIVE OF OUR
MEDICAL CENTER LABORATORIES
HAVE DESIGNED TEST FOR COVERT
NINETEEN AND ALL OF THEM ARE
WORKING THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS. ALLOCATION PROCESS TO
OFFER THAT TESTING. WAS THE
STATE. AS OF YESTERDAY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO ARE OFFERING IN HOUSE
COATED NINETEEN TEST. THE
TURNAROUND TIMES THAT WILL BE
UNDER TWENTY FOUR HOURS SO
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THIS WILL
REALLY- EIGHT AT THE STATE IN
GETTING MORE PEOPLE TESTED. AND
I KNOW THAT MY NEXT TWO LABS UC
IRVINE AND UC DAVIS THEIR TEST
WILL COME ON LINE VERY QUICKLY
AS WELL. AND THEN FINALLY
CONTRIBUTING TO RESEARCH. IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THERE
ARE MANY PRIORITIES. FOR US IN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM PATIENT
CARE IS PRIORITY NUMBER ONE.
THE WONDERFUL THING ABOUT BEING
IN AN ACADEMIC HEALTH CENTER IS
WE ALSO HAVE A RANGE OF
SCIENTISTS WHO WERE THERE TO
HELP US TO HELP THOSE THAT ARE
DELIVERING HEALTHCARE BY
ACTUALLY CONDUCTING RESEARCH
AND ALL OF OUR SCIENTISTS WITH
WITH GATHERED THEM IN MANY
GROUPS TO TACKLE INDIVIDUAL
ISSUES ACROSS- ACROSS THIS
WHOLE. PANDEMIC WE ARE WORKING
ON ADDRESSING IMMEDIATE
CONCERNS IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IS THE ROLE OF
CHILDREN. SHOULD SCHOOLS BE
CLOSED OUR CHILDREN INVOLVED IN
THE TRANSMISSION OF DISEASE IF
WE STOP DISEASE IN CHILDREN
WILL THAT PROTECT OTHERS THESE
ARE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. AND THEN IN
THE HEALTHCARE SETTING HOW LONG
IS A PATIENT INFECTIOUS WHAT
TYPE OF PROTECTION DO WE NEED
OF WINDOWS THEIR INFECTIVITY GO
DOWN AND ALLOW THEM TO BE CARED
FOR AT HOME AND NOT INFECT
OTHERS IN THEIR HOMES. WE KNOW
HOME. POURTANT PLACES OF
TRANSMISSION. AND THEN WE'RE
ALSO ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
LONG TERM RESEARCH PROJECTS
WHICH INCLUDE LOOKING AT THE
GENOMICS OF THE VIRUS
UNDERSTAND. WHERE WE MIGHT BEST
TACKLE THIS VIRUS WITH NEW
TREATMENTS AND VACCINES. AND
THEN FINALLYIS IN THE CLINICAL
TRIALS OF THE TREATMENTS AND
VACCINES THAT WILL BE PROPOSED.
ALL FIVE OF OUR MEDICAL CENTERS
AND- HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH
THE APPROVAL PROCESS TO BE
SELECTED AS CLINICAL TRIAL
SITES FOR RENDA. THE ANTI
PRETTY BY AT WHICH IS BEING
TESTED IN THE UNITED STATES SO
WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
CLINICAL TRIALS FOR THE
TREATMENT AT ALL OF OUR MEN. SO
ONCE AGAIN I'M VERY TO BE
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM WHICH IS
OF WORLDWIDE SIGNIFICANCE AND
VERY VERY CONFIDENT TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
STATE AND COUNTY AND SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DOCTOR BY
INTENT OKAY JUST BEFORE WE
START THE QUESTION AND ANSWER.
SESSION I HAVE SOME THINGS THAT
RULES THE RULES COMMITTEES
WOULD LIKE ME TO STATE BEFORE
WE START. THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS COMING FROM
THE STAFF OF THE LEGISLATURE
CONCERNING OUT ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE ARE RESPONDING TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN OUT BREAK. THE
RULES COMMITTEES OF BOTH HOUSES
ARE IN DAILY COMMUNICATION WITH
STAFF AND MAY HAVE MEMBERS AND
A PROVIDING MET HIM FROM BASED
THE REGULAR CALLED. WITH HEALTH
THANK. AS THE SITUATION
INVOLVES THEY ARE PREPARED TO
RESPOND AND WE'LL COMMUNICATE
ACCORDINGLY. IF STAFF HAVE
PERSONAL QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
THEY SHOULD CONTACT HUMAN.
HUMAN HUMAN RESOURCES IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE HOUSES. GOOD SO WITH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO START THE
AND ANSWER SESSION WILL JUST
OPEN UP THE WHOLE PANEL OF THE
AUDIENCE MAY ASK QUESTIONS BY
RAISING A HAND IN THE HOUSE
WILL COME TO YOU. PLEASE THAT
THE HOST WILL HOLD THE
MICROPHONE FOR YOU. BUT AND YOU
WILL WHEN YOU ASK YOUR QUESTION.
AND WE HAVE. WE ALSO WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS THE DISTRICT OFFICES
AND I HAVE SEVERAL EMAILS HERE
THAT WE CAN GO OVER SERVE WE'D
LIKE WE CAN GO AHEAD AND START.
GREAT THANK YOU I'M RICHARD
THOMAS AND WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION- DOCTOR
ANGEL A QUESTION FOR YOU JUST-
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR-
COMMENTS ABOUT THE LOCAL NATURE
OF THE- DISEASE AS IT'S-
SPREADING AROUND CALIFORNIA.
WHEN IF YOU COULD TALK SOME
MORE ABOUT. HOW YOUR DEPARTMENT
IS GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO
COMMUNITIES IN. ALL THE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES THAT THAT
INFORMATION NEEDS TO GET OUT
IN. AS A WAY OF ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AND
MISINFORMATION THAT'S OUT THERE
THANK YOU. MICROPHONE AREA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I
MAY THINK THAT'S IT RIGHT A
CRITICAL- ISSUE AND- INCREDIBLY
RELEVANT HERE IN CALIFORNIA- WE
HAVE THE HONOR OF HAVING A
GREAT DIVERSITY OF POPULATIONS
A LARGE IMMIGRANT POPULATION.
AND SO- BEING ABLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION AND- LANGUAGE IS
SPECIFIC TO THE ORIGINS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IS CRITICAL SO WE
AT- THROUGH OUR WEBSITE HAVE
THE INFORMATION AVAILABLE IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. WE ALSO
RELY HEAVILY ON THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE- THE
RESOURCES ARE SPECIFIC TO THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY AND
THROUGH- PARTNERS THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE- THAT WORK
WITH SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO. SHARE THAT INFORMATION
AND HELP DISSEMINATED THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA WE'VE ALSO BEEN-
RECORDING- PSA TYPE VIDEOS
PUSHING THEM OUT ANOTHER
LANGUAGES AS WELL WITH-
DIFFERENT CAPTIONING AS WELL-
THIS IS QUICKLY MOVING. SO WE
HAVE. HE CAREFULLY A WHICH
POPULAR WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
PRIOR. GET OUT EARLY AND AS IT
OF ALL WILL CAN TO PUSH. GOOD
AFTERNOON I WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK THIS QUESTION OF
YOUR ELEMENT FOR OTHERS AND
IT'S PROBABLY AN UNFAIR
QUESTION BUT WERE WONDERING
GIVEN YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH
OTHER INFECTIOUS DISEASES HOW
LONG YOU THINK WILL BE IN THIS
MITIGATION PHASE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THERE ARE MILESTONES IN
THE WORK THAT WE DO LIKE
STANDARDIZED TESTING IS COMING
UP- WE NEED TO MAKE POLICY
CHANGES. RELATED TO SORT OF THE
DURATION OF WHAT WE EXPECT THIS
OUTBREAK TO BE IT'S AN UNFAIR
QUESTION I REALIZED BUT IS
THERE A BASS GAS OF HOW LONG
WILL BE IN THIS MEDICAID. STAGE.
IT'S A QUESTION AND I THINK I
APPRECIATE YOUR CARRY OUT THAT
IT. IS IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW- I
THINK PROBABLY THE BEST- SORT
OF TOUCHED ON THAT WE HAVE IS
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE H. ONE
AND ONE- PANDEMIC- AND THAT
REALLY LASTED FOR. MANY MONTHS
AND THEN KIND OF CARRIED OVER
INTO THE FOLLOWING FLU SEASON
SO- I CAN GIVE YOU A PRECISE
ANSWER BUT I DO THINK THAT. ARE
PART. OF PARTNERS OUT THERE WHO
ARE THINKING ABOUT THEIR
PLANNING AND WOOD AND
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
BE THINKING IN ASKING THIS VERY
QUESTION SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT. MONTHS ALSO ADDED ON.
PART OF THIS. AS ENTER GOING
FROM CONTAINMENT TO SORT OF A
MIX CONTAINMENT MITIGATION
APPROACH. IS NOT BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PREVENT EVERY ANY FURTHER
SPREAD WERE REALLY JUST TRYING
TO SLOW IT DOWN- WE WANT TO
SLOW DOWN LONG ENOUGH FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO BRING THE TREATMENTS
ONLINE AND VACCINATIONS ONLINE.
AND WHEN WE GET THOSE TWO VERY
IMPORTANT TOOLS THEN WE SORT OF
MOVE MORE INTO MANAGING THIS
LIKE WE WITH THE FLU ANNUALLY
WHICH MEANS. WE CAN CARDS
EVERYONE TO GET THEIR FLU SHOT
AND THROUGH THAT WERE ABLE TO
REALLY HAVE A BETTER- SENSE OF
MANAGEMENT OF THIS- MANY OF THE
MITIGATION ALSO ACTIVITIES THAT
WE TALK ABOUT. ARE THINGS THAT
JUST MAKES SENSE ANYWAY WITH
RESPECT TO- TO VIRUSES SO IT
THAT WHILE WE TALK ABOUT IS
IT'S- AS IF IT'S SOMETHING
TOTALLY NEW IT'S THE- END THERE
ARE DEFINITELY MEASURES THAT
WERE INTRODUCED IN THAT. WE
HAVEN'T MESSED EARLY INTRODUCED
UP PRIOR MANY OF THEM LIKE
SOCIAL DISTANCING WHEN YOU'RE
ILL AND STAYING HOME ARE THINGS
THAT ARE GOOD PRACTICE FOR US
ANYWAY SO I THINK WILL BENEFIT
FROM LESSONS LEARNED. FOR MUCH
LONGER TIME PERIOD THAN JUST AS
LONG AS THIS CORONA VIRUSES IS
BOTHERING US. THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS WITH THE WRITERS AND
ONLY WITH A SOMEONE REYES OFF I
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE TEST-
TESTING DIAGNOSTIC AND THAT IS
BEING DONE IN THE UC HOSPITALS-
ARE THEY- I CAN OTHER FOR NON
UC FACILITIES ALSO USE THAT
KIND OF TEST AND- FOR THOSE
THAT. AREN'T USING THOSE IN
HOUSE TESTS THINGS WE SO WE
STILL WAITING ON THEM THE
SENATE OVER TO SEND SAMPLES
OVER TO THE CDC IN. ATLANTA
LIKE WHAT WHAT IS HAS SOME LOOK
LIKE RIGHT NOW. SO TESTING
RIGHT NOW- INVOLVES A LOT OF
COORDINATION SO. NOW WE ARE
ABLE TO SEND TEST TO THE- LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND- A LAB
WHICH MEANS THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO ALL THE WAY TO ATLANTA SO
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL AND USEFUL.
AND IS BROUGHT DOWN THE TURN
AROUND TIME. FOR YOU SEE
SPECIFICALLY- OF OUR TESTS ARE
BEING OFFERED. TO THE PATIENTS
THAT ARE PART OF THE UC SYSTEM
IN OUR CLINICS IN IN OUR
HOSPITALS. THE WE HAVE GOTTEN A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS OF FROM. A
AT BY PROVIDERS OF HOW THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ACCESS. THOSE
TESTS AND I HAVE A GROUP THAT'S
CURRENTLY WORKING TODAY OUR
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER'S. TRYING
TO- IDENTIFY WHETHER WE WOULD
HAVE SUFFICIENT CAPACITY OR
ABILITY TO OFFER TESTING FOR
OTHERS. I ALSO KNOW THAT OTHER.
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE DEVELOPING
THEIR OWN TEST AS WELL. AND
THEN FINALLY THERE ARE THINGS
CALLED COMMERCIAL TESTS SO
DEVELOPED BY COMPANIES. AND OUR
LABORATORY DEVELOPED TESTS WILL
HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
CAPACITY. BUT ONCE COMMERCIAL
TESTS ARE APPROVED FOR USE IN
THE UNITED STATES WHICH WERE
EXPECTING BY. OF APRIL. THAT
INCREASES OUR- DRAMATICALLY AND
SO HOPEFULLY THERE BE MANY MANY
MORE WAYS AND IN WHICH- FOR
TEN. IN THE NEXT WEEK. WHOLE
NICOLE JUST FORGET I WANNA
FOLLOW UP WITH ACTOR WE HAVE
YOU FROM MY DISTRICT ALL. THAT
FIT WITH THE TESTING HERE A
WOMAN LOAN FROM THE WHAT
SOMEBODY NO AND NO ABILITY TO
PAY. TO TEST. AND ASKED
CAPACITY. YOU KIND OF TO THIS
ALREADY DONE BY INTO BUT WILL
THE TESTING GET MORE REAL. CAN
SOMEONE EVEN WITH MY SIM THAT
SO POINT. BE ABLE TO BE TO IF
TESTING INCREASE OF TEN BECOMES
IN. LIKE TRY PER OF THOSE BUT
YOU ALL MAY BE TO SAY HOW THE
TESTING AT THE STATE LAW WE
BEEN VERY PLEASED SEE. THROUGH
CALIFORNIA RELEASE OF SOME OF
THE WRIST FOR COPAYS AND SO
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
TESTED WE'RE DOING THE SAME
WITH AND USE FOR OUR- FOR OUR
SELF INSURED- OF. EMPLOYEES AND
FOR OUR STUDENTS WHO WERE ENDS
IN YOUR BY THE HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM. AND THEN AS FAR AS
GETS TO HAVE A TEST. IT'S ALL
RIGHT BE OF THAT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN THE GUIDANCE ALLOWING
CLINICAL JUDGMENT UP SO
ALLOWING THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER O HELP DECIDE IF THE
TEST IS REQUIRED- AND SO THAT
ALREADY IS EXISTING. BUT WE'RE
WE'RE SAYING THAT THEY'RE
STILL- PERHAPS NOT QUITE ENOUGH
TEST. TO ALLOW ALL. AT WHO
WANTS A RIGHT NOW TO HAVE A TO.
BUT IN MAYBE FOR THE STATE
LAPSED VIA. I'M JUST TO ADD TO
THAT AND I WOULD DEFINITELY
WITH THOSE COMMENTS- THE
GUIDANCE FOR WHO SHOULD BE
TESTED HAS DEFINITELY BEEN
EVOLVING OVER TIME BUT JUST IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS THE CDC HAS-
CHANGE THE GUIDANCE AS AS
DOCTOR BYINGTON INDICATED SO
THAT IT'S REALLY NOW UP TO THE
PHYSICIAN TO DECIDE. JUST AS IT
WOULD BE FOR ANY OTHER TEST ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT ROLES OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LABORATORIES IS
TO PROVIDE TESTING- FOR SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES PARTICULARLY AS
WE MOVE INTO A TIME WHEN
TESTING IS MORE WIDELY
AVAILABLE IN. HOSPITAL SETTINGS
OR IN- COMMERCIAL SETTINGS. AND
SO SOME OF THE PLACES WHERE
PUBLIC HEALTH LABS CAN BE OF
SERVICE IS IN SETTINGS WHERE
PERHAPS THERE ARE CHALLENGES
WITH ACCESSING THE TASK. AND SO
THAT'S A PARTICULA ROLE THAT
WE HAVE AND THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SECTOR. I'M GOING
FORWARD. OKAY GO AHEAD MICHAEL
I AM SEASONAL THEM FOR ITS-
WITH LEADERSHIP MORGAN HILL AND
I'M A CHEMICAL ENGINEER SO MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH
MITIGATION. IN TERMS OF THE
SENIOR POPULATION SO ON THE WAR
CHILD YOU'RE TALKING BASICALLY
INFANT TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
SENIOR SURE TALKING SOMEWHERE
FIFTY TWO UP TO A HUNDRED SO
YOU HAVE A BIG VARIETY. OF
PHYSIOLOGICAL CHANGES INTERVIEW
NO RESPONSES SO WHAT WOULD BE
YOUR SUGGESTION IN TERMS OF
TRAVEL FOR A HEALTHY SIXTY YEAR
OLD AS COMPARED TO SOMEONE YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY WHO IS IMMUNO
SUPPRESSED AT THE- AT THAT AGE.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I THINK THAT- INTO SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS ARE DECISIONS
THAT- INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT BASED ON
THEIR OWN HEALTH STATUS AND
POTENTIALLY IN INCOME
CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS I WOULD
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THESE KINDS OF QUESTIONS.
TO TALK TO THEIR DOCTOR ABOUT
THEM CERTAINLY THE RISK DOES
INCREASE WITH AGE- ACROSS THAT
SPAN OF OLDER FOLKS I'M AS WELL
AS AS AS YOU MENTIONED
UNDERLYING HEALTH CARE
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS-
DO PLAY A ROLE- AND I THINK
PEOPLE REALLY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THEIR OWN CIRCUMSTANCES
AND MAKE TO. DECISIONS THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR THE FOR THEM
AND WHAT THEY'RE REALITIES ARE
BUT WE WOULD DEFINITELY-
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
INCREASED RISK TO BE ASKING
THESE KINDS OF QUESTIONS. TO BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
TAKE SOME OF THESE COMMONSENSE
MEASURE LIKE REDUCING THEIR
EXPOSURE TO PEOPLE IN GENERAL
STAYING AWAY FROM PEOPLE WHO
ARE ILL STAYING AWAY SETTING
WHERE TRACK. IT COMMON OR OR OR
OR. THE THANK YOU THINGS
SERIOUSLY WITH TO CRUISES HAS
COME OUT WITH GUIDANCE JUSTIN
LAST FEW DAYS ADVISING WHO ARE
OLDER OR HOW UNDER HEALTH
CONDITIONS TO AVOID CRUISES-
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT'S A PLACE
WHERE TRANSMISSION IF IT DOES
HAPPEN- CAN HAPPEN PRETTY
BROADLY SO I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION OKAY BECAUSE WHAT
I'M SAYING AND BASICALLY A
HEALTHY SYSTEM SAID OF THE
YOUNGER SENIOR. IF YOU CALL IT.
IS THAT THERE A LOT OF. INTO
OUR SOME IS BECAUSE ABOUT YOU I
GO TO THE SHOULD I NOW. IN A BY
EVERY SET OF YOU KNOW EVERY
BOTTLE OF PARRAL OR LYSOL
CLEANER YOU KNOW IS IT SAFE FOR
ME TO PICK UP THE GRAND KIDS
FROM SCHOOL I MEAN I THINK
WE'RE GENERATING A HUGE AMOUNT
OF FEAR FOR. OF A FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE
POPULATION ONE ONLY A PORTION
OF THAT. ARE REALLY HAVE THE-
YOU KNOW- CONCERNS. CAN I JUST
SIT ON A MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT
I THINK IT'S JUST A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT ABOUT-
MISINFORMATION INFORMATION AND
WE THIS IS VERY HELPFUL TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS DIALOGUE
WITH YOU TO ME I FEEL LIKE THIS
ISN'T ONE MORE OF THE DIALOGUE
THAT I HAVE ALL DAY LONG
LEARNING. COMMUNITIES ARE
RESPONDING AND THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT THAT I THINK
THAT WE AND OTHERS PROBABLY
COULD BE A LITTLE MORE CLEAR-
ABOUT MESSAGING WE TALKED TO
POPULATIONS BECAUSE THAT. OUR
AUDIENCE- BUT IF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HERE THAT
INFORMATION IF IT'S CREATING
GREATER CONCERN AND WE REALLY
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
RESPOND TO THAT MESSAGING SO
IT. MIGHT TAKE AWAY FROM THIS
IS TO LOOK BACK AT OUR WEBSITE
TO BE SURE THAT WE HELP PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT. ABOUT THAT
RELATIVE RISK THAT SAID THIS IS
THE WE'RE ALL LEARNING MORE
ABOUT AND IT DOESN'T HURT ANY
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT. IT IS
YOU ARE. ENVIRONMENT LET'S
BEING WITH SIX FEET OF SOMEONE
THAT IS SNEEZING PUTS YOU AT
RISK IF THEY HAVE CO NINETEENTH
JUST BEING AWARE OF THAT
ENVIRONMENT ISN'T- BAD FOR ANY
OF US AND I THINK CAN ALSO HELP
BELIEVE FEAR BECAUSE WE KNOW
HOW IT'S TRANSMITTED AND WE
KNOW THAT WE SHOULD BE WASH
YOUR HANDS FREQUENTLY AT
VETERAN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
CAN. AND ALL JUST. IN UP LITTLE
BIT MORE TO THAT OF HOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE REALLY
ASKING PEOPLE TO EVALUATE OF
ALL TRAVEL. AND WHETHER IT IS
ESSENTIAL OR NON ESSENTIAL AND
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO DEFINE.
WHAT IS ESSENTIAL TRAVEL. AND
IF- IF WE HAVE TO TRAVEL. AND
WE KNOW WE WILL PEOPLE WILL
HAVE TO TRAVEL. DURING THIS
PERIOD OF MONTHS THEN HOW CAN
WE- OUR- DURING TRAVEL. WHAT
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
TO PROTECT OUR- DURING TRAVEL.
IS THERE A WAY. TO DRIVE.
RATHER THAN FLY. IS THERE A
WAY. A IF YOU MUST FLY. CHECK
YOURSELF IN THE ENVIRONMENT
WHEN YOU'RE FLYING AND
CERTAINLY THERE ARE GOOD. OF
STUDIES THAT SHOW SIMPLE THINGS
LIKE WASHING YOUR HANDS. BEFORE
YOU ENTERED PLANE. AND AFTER
YOU LEAVE THE PLANE. CAN GO A
LONG. IN OF. USING THIS FIRE.
I'M I HAD A QUESTION SO MAY I'M-
NOT UNDERSTANDING THE HERE BUT
THERE. WHAT IS THE UNIQUE OF
THE VIRUS THAT IS- MAKING IT SO
DIFFERENT WITH SUCH A REACTION
GLOBALLY AFFECTING. ALL PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY AND COUNTRIES I
GUESS- WHERE ITALY HAD TO SHUT
DOWN ITS BORDERS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT WHAT'S THE UNIQUENESS OF
THIS PARTICULAR. FEEL LIKE IT'S
IT MIGHT CREATING MORE FEAR.
ARE LIKE AS SOME OF THE P. HERE
THIS HERE YEAH WHAT IT WHAT IS
IT SO YOU. VERSUS THE FLU OR
OTHER VIRAL DISEASES. I'D LIKE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION IF I
CAN IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION. OF SO THIS VIRUS IS A
CORONA VIRUS AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF KNOWN HUMAN CORONA
VIRUSES THAT WE LIVE WITH ALL
THE TIME. EVERY YEAR AND THEY
CALL BECAUSE JUST SIMPLE COLDS
AND NO ONE EVEN THINKS ABOUT
THEM. SO WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
THIS ONE IS IT'S NEW. WE HAVE
NOT SEEN IT BEFORE. SO UNLIKE
OTHER VIRUSES THAT HAVE ADAPTED
TO INFECT HUMAN BEINGS THAT WE
LIVE WITH REGULARLY BECAUSE OUR
IMMUNE SYSTEMS ARE USED TO
THEM. THIS IS A NEW VIRUS. OUT
WE BELIEVE IT COMES FROM AN
ANIMAL AND ANIMAL ORIGIN
PROBABLY A BAT AND PERHAPS
ANOTHER MAMMAL THAT IT MAY HAVE
INTERACTED WITH BEFORE IT CAME
TO HUMANS. AND WE HAVE NO
UNDERLYING IMMUNITY FOR THIS
VIRUS. AND SO ESSENTIALLY
EVERYONE IS POTENTIALLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE VIRUS AND
THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT VERY
UNIQUE- EVERY FLU STRAIN THAT
COMES EACH YEAR OR- OR EVERY.
REGULAR CORONA VIRUS THAT COMES
EACH YEAR THERE'S A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HAVE SOME
IMMUNITY OR THERE MAY BE
VACCINES TO HELP US BECOME MORE
IMMUNE TO THE PARTICULAR VIRUS.
AND IN THIS SITUATION IT'S JUST
NEW AND SO THAT'S WHY IT IS
DIFFERENT AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
BEHAVING IN THE WAY THAT YOU'RE
SAYING IT BEHAVE NOW. AND I
WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK ON TO
THAT JUST BECAUSE THE QUESTION
THE DISTRICT OFFICE CAN WE
EXPECT THE VIRUS TO DECREASE IN
THE SUMMER AND GET. POTENTIALLY
WORSE IN THE FALL SIMILAR TO
THE SPANISH FLU IN NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS A QUESTION
THAT WE GET ASKED A LOT BECAUSE-
MANY RESPIRATORY VIRUSES DO
EXACTLY THAT DATE THEY PEAK IN
THE WINTER AND SPRING AND-
DECREASE IN THE SUMMER AND THEN
BEGIN TO START TO COME BACK IN
THE FALL- WE DON'T KNOW YET
WHAT THIS VIRUS IS GOING TO DO.
I HOPE THAT WE'LL SEE SOME
DECLINE IN THE SUMMER- BECAUSE
OTHER RESPIRATORY VIRUSES DO
THAT BUT I CAN'T PROMISE THAT
THAT WILL HAPPEN. THANK YOU SO
I'M GONNA ASK YOU A FEW
QUESTIONS FROM THE OFFICES THE
DISTRICT OFFICES AND WE'LL GO
FROM THERE WHAT SHOULD WE TELL
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT GETTING THEIR MEDICATION
AND A POSSIBLE QUARANTINE HOW
DO YOU GET EXTRA MEDICATION
BEFORE IS DUE FOR A REFILL
EXPRESSION OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES WILL PAY UNTIL IT IS
TIME FOR A REFILL. I NEED TO
GET BACK TO YOU BECAUSE OUR
INSURANCE LANDSCAPE IS- VARIED
AND DIVERSE AND INCLUDES BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PAYERS. SO
OF WILL SEND BACK SOME
RESOURCES ARE REFERENCES THAT
PEOPLE CAN USE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT'S GETTING OUT
IS THIS QUESTION OF GENERAL
PREPAREDNESS. SO THIS IS A
GREAT MOMENT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY WE LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE WILD FIRES WE HAVE-
EARTHQUAKES. WE HAVE POWER SHUT
DOWNS AND NOW HAVE. WE HAVE
COVERED NINETY. AND IT'S NOW A
IDEA TO BE PER. ALL THE TIME
FOR ANY OF THESE SO MAKING SURE
THAT YOU TALK WITH YOUR
PHYSICIAN AHEAD OF TIME ABOUT
GETTING MEDICATIONS MAKING SURE
THAT YOU HAVE THEM- AT HOME. IN
CASE THINGS GET INCONVENIENT OR
ON THERE'S A PROBLEM GET YOUR
MEDICATION IT DOESN'T BECOME
SOMETHING THAT LIMITS YOUR
ABILITY OR GETS YOU IN- IN
TROUBLE PARTICULARLY AT A TIME
WHEN THERE. COULD BE A LEVEL OF
INCONVENIENCE AND SOME SOCIAL
DISRUPTION SO. GOOD REMINDER TO
GET THOSE MEDICATIONS REFILLED.
AT NICHOL. RIGHT NOW ALL I SEE
WHAT HIS AND I WANTED TO GRAB
IT OUT OF OUR HANDS BJ PART
ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE WENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK ALL
OF YOU HAVE DONE IN CONCERT
WITH US TO DEAL WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES I HAVE A
COMMON QUESTION- WE CAN'T OVER
EMPHASIZE THE WORK THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO DO
WITH YOU PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT RELATIVE TO THE- WELL.
CAN IMAGINE STRESS THAT FEELING
AN ARMORED DEPARTMENT AND I
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING WE ARE POISED
AND READY TO DOING CONTINUE TO
DO WITH YOU AND THEN I HAD A
KIND OF AN ODD QUESTION BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO LOOK AT
IT BUT WE'VE WE'VE ALL BEEN
LOOKING AT THE CHINA EXPERIENCE
ARE AND IF YOU UNDERSTANDING
THE ITALY EXPERIENCE IS THE
DEATH RATE HIGHER THERE ARE IT
SEEMS. AGAIN NOT REALLY LOOKING
AT ME I THOUGHT ON THE ITALY
EXPERIENCE. I'M THAT'S A
TERRIFIC. I THINK. WE ARE
LIKELY. LEARN FROM THE ITALY.
BUT IT'S- TOO NEW SO THERE
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN ANY
PUBLICATIONS COMING OUT OF
ITALY DESCRIBING THINGS IN ANY
DETAIL. SO BUT WE PICK THINGS
CAME FROM OUR CHINESE
COLLEAGUES. DID A TREMENDOUS
JOB OF PROVIDING INFORMATION
VERY QUICKLY AND HOPEFULLY WILL
ALSO BEGIN TO SEE THINGS- FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US IN THE
UNITED STATES TO SEE KIND OF
THE- CITY OF WHAT HAPPENS-
DIFFERENT PLACES. AND I'D JUST
LIKE TO THANK THE- OF. THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
TO IT'S BEEN REMARKABLE TO.
WORK WITH BOTH A CH A AND C. M.
A. DURING THIS TIME AND TO ACT
I FEEL A GREAT DEAL OF SUPPORT
FOR OUR- TRADITIONS. GIVE VERY.
AT. KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF THE
CAL. MEDICAL SO. WE THE COLLAB
AND I THINK THIS HEARING IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT EDUCATES
EVERYONE AND WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS VERY
EDUCATED ABOUT THIS IN
COMBATING ALL OF THE
MISINFORMATION THAT'S OUT
THERE. BUT LIKE DOCTOR UNTIL
SAID I THINK THAT WE SHOULD ALL
AND YOU KNOW BE RESPECTFUL AND
ALSO COMPORT OURSELVES. AND DO
WE SHOULD ALREADY BE DOING I
MEAN ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU
MENTIONED SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ANOTHER SHOUT OUT TO
ALL OUR PARTNERS BECAUSE
ABSOLUTELY THIS IS NOT ONLY AT
ALL OF GOVERNMENT IS THAT ALL
OF STATE RESPONSE AND- FROM OUR
ACADEMIC SETTINGS TO OUR
ASSOCIATIONS ARE CARE PROVIDERS
ARE. THE NACAC ALL OF YOU I.
THE LIST IS A MILLION SOTHAT'S
WHY WE DO SO WELL BECAUSE WE
WORK WERE WORKING WELL TOGETHER
SO APPRECIATED. HEY SO I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT- KIND OF HOW IT
FEELS LIKE FOLKS ARE WINGING IT
OUT THERE IN TERMS OF DECISIONS
ARE MAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE. JUST
OBVIOUSLY THE FIELD OF SPORTS
OF SOME TEAMS ARE PLAYING PHONE
EMPTY STADIUM SUMMER PLAYING
FULL FOR THE FULL STADIUM
SUMMER. SOME SCHOOL DISTRICT-
SHOWING SOME ARE NOT. IS THERE
ANYWAY TO BRING CONSISTENCY OR
DO WE WANT TO BRING CONSISTENCY
TO THIS DECISION OR IS IT GOOD
TO BE OUT OF HOCK. IS FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A SENSATIONALISM OR ON
ALL THESE. DECISIONS TO MAKE
BIG MOVES TO CANCEL CONCERTS AT
SUCH A- AND JUST LOSE THE REST
OF US WONDERING WHAT'S THE
RIGHT IDEA WHAT'S NOT. THANK
ECHOING WHEN I KNOW WE KEEP
SAYING BUT THIS IS OF ALL BEING
INCREDIBLY RAPIDLY AND WHEN
EVER ANYTHING INVOLVES RAPIDLY.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A DIVERSITY
OF RESPONSES AND- IT TO WARD
THAT AND TO WORDS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT REALLY TRYING TO
CREATE. CONSISTENCY IN OUR
STATE. THE WAY WE AT YOU KNOW.
HAVE THE WAY WE WORK IS. WE
HAVE A VERY STRONG AND VERY-
KNOWLEDGEABLE LOCAL- GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND AS A STATE WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM AND SO
OUR STATE IS SO LARGE WE WILL
SEE DIVERSITY ON THE WAY THINGS
ARE HANDLED BUT OUR
RESPONSIBILITY ALSO AT THE
STATE LEVEL IS TO ISSUE
GUIDANCE WHEN THE EVIDENCE IS
VERY CLEAR THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE SO YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE SEEING GUIDANCE-
FORTHCOMING SOON REGARDING MANY
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU WERE
MENTIONING AND THEY CONTINUE TO
ROLL OUT AND THERE ARE MANY
ALREADY GUIDANCE IS OUT ABOUT-
ABOUT GATHERINGS IT SAID DR BUT
BUT AS THIS PROGRESSES AND WE
SEE WHERE THE VIRUSES GOING AND
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE NUMBERS
INCREASING. YOU'LL SEE OFF MORE
SPECIFICS ABOUT- AT LARGER
GATHERINGS AS WELL. LET ME LET
ME TAKE A THE A FEW OF THESE
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO WRAP UP
WITH YOUR JOB IN THERE. OKAY I
JUST WANNA GET SOME OF OUR
DISTRICT EMAILS SO THAT. THEY
GET SOME WORK SOME. TO ANSWER.
SHOULD VISIT TO THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SUCH AS LOBBYING
ORGANIZATIONS CONSIDER SCALING
BACK IN. BACK IN PERSON VISITS
WHAT IF THEY FALL INTO THE
HIGHER RISK CATEGORY OR LIVE
WITH FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE AT
HIGHER RISK SHOULD THEY BE HERE.
I CAN I CAN TAKE THAT ONE- WE
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT ALL
PEOPLE- CONSIDER. ARE THE
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE
ENGAGING IN AND WHETHER THE AT
THERE IS ADDITIONAL RISK THEY
THEY SHOULD KNOW IF THEY FALL
IN A PARTICULAR RISK CATEGORY
AND- AND WHAT THEY CAN DO TO
MINIMIZE THEIR EXPOSURE.
PARTICULARLY IN THIS TIME WHEN
WE'RE ENGAGED IN ACTIVE
MITIGATION TRYING TO DECREASE
THOSE CHAINS OF TRANSMISSION-
WOULD BE BEST FOR THEM TO.
EITHER PARTICIPATE AT DISTANCE
OR TO FOR GO PARTICIPATION.
OKAY AT ANY POINT WITH THE
STATE CONSIDER COMPLETE SHUT
DOWN OF SCHOOLS AND LARGE
GATHERINGS. I KNOW THAT SCHOOLS
IN LARGE GATHERINGS ARE ARE
SOMETHING THAT'S ON THE MIND OF
MANY PEOPLE- WE ARE
CONTINUOUSLY LOOKING AT THE
PATTERN OF MOVEMENT OF THIS
DISEASE ACROSS OUR STATES ARE
COMMUNITIES IN THE IMPLICATION
OUR OUR OUR COUNTIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE
IMPLICATIONS THAT HAS. IN TERMS
OF PROTECTING MOST IMPORTANTLY
OUR UP MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND ARE CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND ANY
DECISIONS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE MAKE WILL REALLY BE
GUIDED BY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THOSE DECISIONS THE IMPACT IT
CAN HAVE ON HELPING TO PROTECT
THOSE TWO SYSTEMS SO- THAT'S TO
SAY. IT. INTERVENTIONS ARE
REALLY NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
HELP CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU I
JUST HAVE TO MORE THAN ALL HAVE
HIM FINISH APART HER PARA A
BRIEFING FOR TODAY CAN THE
PANEL SPEAK ABOUT AS MUCH AS A
RISK FACTOR FOR MORE SEVERE
COVERT ILLNESS FOR BOTH THE
ADULT AND CHILDREN POPULATION
SHOULD PEOPLE AS MY EVEN MILD
ASTHMA. BE TAKING GREATER
PRECAUTIONS NOW. I WILL COMMENT
ON CHILDHOOD ASTHMA. ALL
RESPIRATORY INFECTIONS ARE A
RISK FOR CHILDREN WITH ASTHMA.
AND IT IS COMMON PRACTICE FOR
PEDIATRICIANS TO DISCUSS THIS
WITH FAMILIES- TO PREPARE THEM
IN THE FALL FOR THE FOR GOING
THROUGH WINTER RESPIRATORY
SEASON. SO WE ROUTINELY
RECOMMEND INFLUENZA VACCINATION
AND- MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
TAKING THEIR PREVENTATIVE
MEDICATIONS AND THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR USUAL. OF MEDICATION SUCH
AS INHALERS IF THEY WERE TO
HAVE AN ATTACK. AT HAND SO THIS
IS COMMON PRACTICE OF FOR ALL
CHILDREN WITH ASTHMA DURING
RESPIRATORY SEASON AND I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THIS RESPIRATORY
VIRUS LIKE ALL OTHERS. WOULD
POSE A RISK FOR CHILDREN WITH
ASTHMA. THANK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION A- DISTURBANCE SPEAK
IS THERE A PLAN TO NOTIFY
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES WHEN THERE
HAS BEEN A COVERT NINETEEN
DEATH IN THEIR DISTRICT SO THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE CAN
RESPOND TO COMMUNITY CONCERNS.
SURE SO WE HAVE BEEN- PROVIDING
INFORMATION ABOUT CASES ON OUR
WEBSITE AND- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THAT- INCLUDES THE DESK
THAT WE'VE HAD IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE HAD SOME- AND SO IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
OF. BENEFIT TO LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
DO WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO
MAKING INFORMATION AVAILABLE-
TO THE COMMUNITY- ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THIS DISEASE-
AND I THINK THAT- THAT HELPS
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND FEEL LIKE- YOU
KNOW- THE PARTNERSHIP WITH.
WITH THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE IS THERE AND THAT THEY
CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE IN
WHAT THEY'RE SEEING AND KNOW
WHERE TO GO TO GET GOOD
INFORMATION. THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
THANKS RICHARD WITH BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION AGAIN
ACTUALLY TWO LAST QUESTIONS
WANT WANT TO COME BACK TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT IF YOUR
UNINSURED AND YOU WANT TO GET
TESTED WHAT DO YOU DO I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR- THE WRIST ANSWER
THEIR- SECOND QUESTION FOR
DOCTOR BYINGTON LOOKING AT THE
ITALY EXPERIENCE IT LOOKS LIKE
THE KEY ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
THAT HAPPENS IS THAT ARE ICY
USE GET OVERWHELMED PRETTY
QUICKLY. SOME WONDERING HOW YOU
SEE IS PLANNING FOR THAT
EVENTUALITY AND THINKING ABOUT
THAT- HAPPENING OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS SO ALL OF THE UC
HOSPITALS HAVE SURGE PLANS THAT
ARE OF DEVELOPED IN IN PLACE SO
SHOULD WE HAVE A SURGEON OR
AGENCY AND OUR INTENSIVE CARE
UNITS- ARE ARE QUITE- INVOLVED
IN THE PREPARATION OF THOSE
PLANS WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF VENTILATORS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WE. HOW MUCH
STAFFING WE WOULD NEED TO
CONVERT THINGS LIKE OUR-
HOSPITAL- ARE ARE SORRY OUR
SURGICAL RECOVERY ROOMS INTO
ADDITIONAL BEDS SO THERE THERE
IS- CERTAINLY SEARCH PLANNING-
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT ALTHOUGH
THE EXPERIENCE WITH ITALY IS
SHORT SO FAR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS COME OUT DISTINCT FROM
CHINA IS THE NEED FOR INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT BEDS CHINA WAS ABLE
TO BUILD TWO. HOSPITALS TWO ONE
THOUSAND BED HOSPITALS IN A TWO
WEEK PERIOD FOR COBIT PATIENTS
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT ITALY WILL
BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND I KNOW
THAT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO
THAT SO WE ARE REALLY LOOKING
AT SEARCH ALL A QUESTION OF- OF
THE UNINSURED. THE UC HEALTH
SYSTEM ALREADY CARES FOR A
LARGE NUMBER OF UNINSURED
PATIENTS ACROSS- OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE TESTING EVERYONE WHO
COMES TO US THAT NEEDS A
MEDICAL TEST AND WE HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO TEST FIRST AND WE
WILL FIGURE OUT THE PAYMENT
MODEL SECOND I AM HOPING THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME KIND OF
FEDERAL LEAVE FOR HOSPITAL WHO
ARE MAKING INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL BE UNREIMBURSED- THROUGH
THE NORMAL A PAIR MECHANISM.
WE'VE DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS
LIKE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW- OF
NEW BETS WE'VE- WE RUN AN
INCIDENT COMMAND CENTER OR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THESE ARE
REAL OF CALL UP IN THAT IT WILL
NEVER BE REIMBURSED BY
INSURANCE SO I BELIEVE THAT AS
AS AS A- NATION WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE WILL-
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR THESE THAT'S
WHEN THE FOR. AND NOTE THAT ON
MARCH FIFTH THE GOVERNOR AND
NOW THE- ELIMINATING COST
SHARING- RELATED TO COPAYS
ETCETERA FOR THOSE PARTICULARLY
IN CALIFORNIA'S COMMERCIAL
HEALTH CARE PLANS ALSO TO
COMPLIMENT ALL OF THE OTHER
WAYS IN WHICH WE- SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS NEEDING MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TESTS FOR KOBE
NINETEEN. AT LAST QUESTION
PROMISE ARE YOU HAD MENTIONED
ON ONE OF OUR PANELISTS
MENTIONED ABOUT COMMERCIAL
BASKETS WERE IT WILL THERE BE
GUIDANCE ON YOU KNOW USING WE
SHOULD BE BY BECAUSE I COULD
JUST ENVISION. IF WE ARE PANIC
BUYING ON TOILET PAPER PAPER
TOWEL AND WATER RIGHT NOW WE
WILL A LOT OF OUR POPULATION
WILL PROBABLY BE PANIC BUYING
ON THIS COMMERCIAL DESK AT
SCHOOL COULD YOU JUST AB WILL
THERE BE FORTHCOMING GUIDANCE
COULD SOMEBODY JUST ADDRESS
THAT PLEASE. SURE THANK YOU- I
THINK I WANT TO REITERATE THAT
THE THAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO TALK TO THEIR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THEY NEED TO BE TESTED. SO
THIS TEST LIKE ANY OTHER
MEDICAL CAST- SHOULD BE. DONE
WHEN IT'S MEDICALLY NECESSARY
SO WE WOULD NOT THAT AND THERE
WILL NOT. BE THERE'S NOT A PLAN
RIGHT NOW TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE AN OVER THE
COUNTER TYPE OF TEST- BUT IF
PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY ARE ILL
AND NEED. AND NEED CARE. THEY
SHOULD TALK TO THEIR DOCTOR IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR DOCTOR
THERE WOULD BE A DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER DOING THIS TEST. MAKES
SENSE OR NOT. OKAY THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR COMING THANK YOU
PANELISTS. I WANT TO PUT SOME
LEVITY INTO THIS WE'VE BEEN
ASKED WHY ARE WE ALL SITTING
APART FROM EACH OTHER. AD SO
WHY WE'RE DOING THAT IS WERE
ROLE MODELING HOW WE WANT YOU
TO SIT WHEN WE WHEN WE CONSIDER
SOCIAL DISTANCING AT THIS TIME
WE ALL STILL LIKE EACH OTHER.
ANYWAY BEFORE WE ADJOURN WE
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT
CLOROX WIPES AND HAND
SANITIZERS CAN BE ORDERED
THROUGH THE SUDDENLY AND SENATE
INTRANET THESE ITEMS MAY BE ON
BACK ORDER BUT ORDER ANYWAY
THESE ITEMS ARE NOT ARE ARE FOR
STAFF AT WORK NOT FOR
CONSTITUENTS OVER THE STAFF
TAKE HOME. PLEASE BE PREPARED
PRUDENT WHEN ORDERING LASTLY
REMEMBER THAT YOUR BEST DEFENSE
IS GOOD HAND HYGIENE AND
RESPIRATORY ETIQUETTE. IF YOU
HAVE A FEVER STAY HOME SELF
ISOLATING CONTRACTORS PROVIDER
AND HUMAN RESOURCES IF YOU NEED
HELP ED IF YOU STAY HOME WE'RE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER THANK YOU
FOR COMING HAVE A GREAT
AFTERNOON.